hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday yeah February 24th 2024 what are
you going to do today this is the only
February 5th 2024 you're ever going to
get what are you going to do to make it
special
um I want to start doing some Instagram
where I just sit there and
act like I know a bunch of
L sitting there going like you
know 70% of divorces over the age of 40
are initiated by
women and you know what happens over 40
their hormones go crazy it's like who
the are you what credentials do you
have are you still
married does your husband like
you when his friends bring up hey how's
how's how's Sarah doing does he kind of
give him the
look does he shake his
head does he smile
warmly who the are you like all of
these Instagram all these
cooking videos and all that like
oh my God this is the last poached egg
recipe you're ever going to
need you're doing this exercise and now
your back is
cured I I don't think I'm I'm looking at
the
video with your dumb sound
effects um and then all these
all these gas combustion guys
who can't just drive a gas combustion
engine they got to sit there and trash
electric cars and they're all afraid of
them you know what I love about the
right I love how they always act
like they're these tough people that you
can't hurt and like they they're
in their feelings just as much as
liberals you know your feelings
it's like what about your
feelings hey do you really need that
machine gun oh yeah you can't take my
guns
where M this is my favorite thing about
these dumb gun owners which I
have no problem with somebody owning a
gun I think it's a smart thing to do
right but these people when they
sit there I have a gun collection to
protect myself from a tyrannical
government it's like well what the
are you waiting
for what are you wait what what do they
have to do before you're going
to protect yourself
what more could they have taken it's
just like the level of greed The
Disappearance of the middle
class they can record all your
conversations and listen to them the
amount of Rights you've lost since a
9/11 taxes inflation all of this
one Corporation buying up all the
houses and I not yet it ain't
tyrannical yet it's just
like I don't think that's why they have
their
guns I think a lot of these people who
act like they're paying attention to the
government are really not doing it
they're just making sure a group of
people that are not the same color of
them if they come up the street they can
mow them down I think that that's what
they mean oh Bill bur coming in hot
baby what else am I going to do this is
the experimental Sunday before the Super
Bowl it's it kind of lets you
know what it's going to be like until
the end of August with no
football just just goes by so quick
every goddamn year
um anyway if the I don't know what the
line is but I'm telling you bury the
Chiefs Chiefs don't lose they just
don't Patrick Mahomes Brock pie I mean
they're not even in the same
convers the amount of help Brock p is
going to need from the rest of his
team look at Patrick Mahomes you saw the
other day without a shirt off he has
that little uh I eat donuts
belly and people are giving him
about it I'm going to tell you right now
that's what quarterbacks look like in
the 1970s nobody had a washboard middle
they were smoking cigarettes drinking
coffee and having a
Danish um there was a few jacked people
but there was a lot of fatties
I'll tell you who was jacked in the NFL
in his whole life the late great cyle
weather um
have to give a shout out to him um the
passing of an
absolute
legend legend uh
transcending um show business the fact
that that guy you know made it in two
completely different areas he made it to
the NFL became a pro football player
played for the Oakland Raiders and his
career
ends and he goes to Hollywood and and
becomes one of the biggest stars they
ever had and one of the biggest
franchises ever you know there's a lot
of
people that try to go from
Sports into being like a movie star and
he I'm trying to think of somebody else
who did it
uh maybe the rock I guess you'd say
sports entertainment wrestling or
whatever but I'm trying to think of a
football or a baseball player oh maybe
The
Rifleman The Rifleman was a uh was a p I
believe in Major League Baseball all
right I'm babbling anyway rest in peace
to him thank you so much for the uh
Incredible movies The Unbelievable
work um I mean he was one of those guys
you just saw him in a movie in the 80s
and like you went from the movie theater
to the
gym it was just
inspiring um anyway I'll tell you what
wasn't
inspiring the other night you know a lot
of people you know when I tell them
where I'm
from and I tell them you know I watch
sports and everything they say hey your
Celtics your Celtics are going to the
finals like it's a done
deal and as i' I've said forever the
regular season is the regular season the
playoffs is something completely
different and I saw
something that um did not give me a lot
of faith in this
team the Boston Celtics are at home
playing the Los Angeles Lakers all right
first things first LeBron James and
Anthony Davis aren't
playing which is ridiculous to
me cuz Back In The Day Magic and Kareem
would have to be missing a limb to not
play in that
game not only are they not playing
they're hanging at the end of the bench
they're cracking jokes laughing and
I'm just joking around and
it's like you look good enough to play
to me you should be laying there in
Agony if you're not playing in
this game so they're not playing
in the game they're two biggest
stars so now it's like you know I don't
know what it's like the summer league
Lakers versus the Boston Celtics all of
our guys Tatum
holiday um
everybody you know Jaylen Brown
everybody's playing presing pringus
everybody's playing and we come
out
flat like it's oh their big guys aren't
playing B like this isn't sex a sexy
game anymore I don't see myself getting
that many highlights on ESPN meanwhile
the Lakers
players that were coming in off the
bench are trying to prove that they
still belong there Lakers of 500 you
know they're going to make a bunch of
moves they're playing for a spot on the
team they came out and just kicked our
ass the whole game they were up
by 15 close to 20 at one point and then
the end of the game they wi by like
nine that is not a good sign in order to
to win a championship you have to have a
killer Instinct Michael Jordan
would have taken it personally that
LeBron and AD weren't going to play and
he would have gone out there and scored
like at least
40 he wouldn't be like oh they're not
playing
the it's kind of hard to get up for this
game I just think that like hopefully
our coach said something like that and
that loss is used as a catalyst to get
their
heads right
because that was just a
needless pathetic loss and uh I
I don't I
don't I don't like that what what that
says about us we should have got up for
that remember that year with the 96
Bulls where uh Jordan just came
up with that thing said the third
quarter is ours and most of the time
they would be up at the half but they
would come out in the third quarter and
just kill any sort of
idea dream hope or will that you had to
win that
game and uh they were doing that in the
regular
season and uh I don't know I'm not
saying you
know you know who the knows what's
going to happen but um that was not a
good that was not a good sign that was
a that was a an embarrassing
embarrassing loss and congratulations to
those Lakers players that went out there
and treated it like a
game
um haven't said that I've been watching
Paul V's Nicks and for the first time
since I've known Paul verie I believe in
the
Knicks
um that is going to be a dangerous team
I think they're going to upset somebody
in the playoffs all right now this is
Billy redface I'm usually a
hockey guy I usually don't watch the
NBA but I've been watching it a
little bit you know with the kids
they're always watching uh all of these
talk and train shows and
everything so every time I go to put on
you know the hockey the center ice
package you know the Bruins don't seem
to be playing so um I know they're at
the allstar break so I got to I got to
get in uh I got to get in some
ice time here and watch the Bruins but I
have been I've been lucky lately
catching the Celtics or whatever so
that's my take on it I'm not quitting
the Celtics I'm not saying I don't like
the Celtics I'm not saying they got to
get rid of their players I'm just saying
that that loss was not a good
message to the league they should have
come
out you
know and show no
mercy I feel who knows or maybe this is
just me because uh I'm on the third day
of my fast which is going to be ending
here in 11 hours
[Music]
um and I don't know when I do these
fasts I always
like wait for that moment where I'm
supposed to be have that feeling of
euphoria or that feeling of Peace
granted I don't meditate or
anything when I fast all I just think
about is what I want to
eat you know so I don't feel like I'm
fasting it's more like I'm starving and
you're just sitting here thinking about
food
as far as like I feel like
fasting probably came from like India
there's so many great things so many
great things came from India before
England came in and just the
whole thing up
um it was probably you went on a fast
you sat in the Lotus
position you centered yourself you got
you you quieted your mind and then after
a couple two three days you you saw
things clearly the one thing I as
opposed to when I do it I just sort of
continue to live my
life and then I just start every day in
my head the breakfast burrito that I'm
going to get gets bigger and bigger hey
um New Yorkers when you come out to LA
okay it's not New York just they keep
making these videos get a
breakfast burrito I can tell you where
to go they don't have anything like that
in New
York the ones that they have out here
are there's like two or three
places just like in New York there's
there's like a half dozen unbelievable
places to get pizza and then there's the
rest that's you know anywhere from good
to just drunk food right same thing with
same thing in any City so um if you'd
like to know where to go uh I can give
you the heads up all right or if you
come out to my show I can give you the
heads up and that's what you do
when you travel you don't go and try and
get what you can get right outside your
door for some reason New Yorkers
I they just don't understand that I
think people that live in Paris are the
same way you know they live in such an
amazing City that they just like they
just look down on every other place that
they go to and they they really
miss out so
anyway that's all I've been thinking
about is like the first day of the fast
was I wanted a
burger and then ever since yesterday I
just keep picturing this glorious
breakfast burrito that I want to eat
which of course coming off a fast you
can't do that
I usually have like a little bit of
um like
cantaloupe and just some avocado just
easy to digest like baby food
and what I do like about that is it's
not like a shock to the system because
believe
me believe me by by 9:00 tonight if
somebody said do you want to go to
McDonald's I would say ABS
lutely and I would get oh what would my
McDonald's order be
two quart no two double
cheeseburgers if they would make
them okay that's my favorite McDonald's
sandwich a close second is the quarter
pounder with cheese so if they weren't
making the double cheese I would get
two4 Pounders with
cheese all right so what am I up to now
like immediately I think I'm over 2,000
calories that's not even with the
fries I get one large
fry like no nobody needs to eat that
many it's too much potatoes and
it just it just fills you
up um and then I would get maybe two
cheeseburgers and
uh maybe a vanilla shake for some reason
not chocolate which I usually go i' get
a vanilla
shake and I would sit there in my car
barely getting out of the
drive-thru
did I ever tell you guys how much I
used to love McDonald's when I
was a young man that was my
favorite my favorite thing to do
after boozing was to go to Mickey D's
hit the
drive-thru and order like $11 worth of
food in like 1986 so that's like you
know 25 bucks I remember one of my
buddies we went there he ordered 3/4
Pounders with chees back when they came
in the styrofoam
box and uh my buddy was in and and then
there was one of my buddies in front of
him who was so stoned he ordered a
medium french fry before they had one
and that person was looking on the
keyboard trying to
find
um Anyway by the time I got to my my
food and I ordered what I ordered I came
back and he was polishing off already
he was polishing off his third quarter
pounder and he had all all the Styrofoam
boxes were open stacked on top of each
other and he had such a look of
satisfaction on his face I just started
cracking up
laughing I was like Jesus oh my God that
weekend that weekend I believe
we we were going up to New Hampshire and
we had rented this
place and we just were underage we were
drinking and then we just left and
didn't
pay it was yeah it just bad I mean I
wasn't into doing that but everyone was
doing it so I was like all
right all right I guess this is what
we're doing you know when that
happens when you just sort of you just
kind of go with it like cuz I actually
had the money that's the one thing I've
had a job since third grade I had a
paper root in third grade I never had a
allowance it was a brief time
I'd shine my Dad's shoes get your
shine box freckles and but you
know he wasn't consistent with the
payments so I had to drop him as a
customer and then I I got a paper roote
in third grade and I kept the paper root
right up until I was a freshman in high
school I started getting taller than
some of my customers and then I got a
workers's permit to get a job oh my God
that job at Morse
shoe G and I was pulling these computer
tickets it was the most mind-numbing
job
ever and then by then I could be 16 then
you could legally work and then I just
started working in warehouses I've had a
job ever since but what was great was I
always remember all my friends are
always having a bum money off their
parents you know they'd be at
lunch high school lunch they didn't have
any money and I always had you
know five 10 bucks which was like having
like a $100 bill on you when you were at
that age age I always had money to feed
myself you know so
uh yeah I've always I I've never been uh
I've always worked so I've never been
broke I've had times where I was
thinking I didn't have enough money to
make my rent but I always had gigs and
and I always saved the money I was
always smart always drove like a
piece of car
uh until I could afford a nice
one um but I will say I I probably took
it too far when I was younger going back
there's a few things I was like man why
didn't I just get one of those
cars you know just to have a cool car
when I was younger I didn't I just had a
nerdy two wheeel drive Ford
Ranger but I always had money I
always had
money always
worked um and speaking of that like you
know I was telling you guys how you know
I'm really entertaining this idea of
just buying a classic car every year and
then after a year selling it and then
getting something else so I can
um just
enjoy these cars that America Europe you
know Asia just these works of
art um I posted one today on
Instagram of this BMW and it's
just I mean it it's it's as fun as fun
to drive I would imagine just as it is
to just look at it it's just absolutely
gorgeous but anyway um I'm going to
these
websites and every car that I look at
it's they all seem like they're 2530
Grand too high like I don't get what the
is going
on with these
prices like Porsches I saw this guy had
a 1986 Porsche 930 so I'm like God let
me see what those things go for so I
look up an 86 it was a you know guy was
just showing Barn fine right not a bar
wasn't a find he just had it in his
garage and
um I was just sitting there going yeah I
wonder what these things what's you know
the Hemmings price on these
things so I saw that there was a turbo
I'm like well if you're going to do
it let's do it right let's get the turbo
1986 Porsche 930 Turbo $1
130,000 to
$170,000 it's like
what for a 38 old Porsche that's I I
mean I maybe it's a classic I don't
know doesn't make any sense
these
um I tell you what I really like is um I
love a a car with a I I like
when it's not matching numbers I don't
that once it's matching numbers it all
those baby boomer
bankers and oil men come in and start
bidding 200 grand for a 83
Bronco to whatever the it is that
they're
doing
um I like like one of those uh
horrifically underpowered s mobiles once
they had the catalytic converter and all
of that and they would call
it like a hearse s 442 and it
had like 190
horsepower
um but the thing about those cars is
they have a giant engine bay so I've
just been going on the internet
searching those years with big block in
the search and lo and behold there's a
bunch of people that threw the
engine in it that you know they couldn't
legally put in it
and I'm looking at it like that's what
the I'm talking about like
something like that like a late
7s Oldsmobile cutless 442 with those
bucket
seats that only had 190 horsepower so
none of these baby boomers want
that and then some you know
you either buy it and take the
engine out and have it done right or
some Gearhead threw something in
there just drive that thing
around for a year I don't like that
whatever that shifter is where
there's like three shifters I
don't even understand what the hell that
is um it's like you're flying a plane
from the 1930s but
anyway anyway we got the Super Bowl
coming up everybody and um I'm going to
Las Vegas and I'm going to put a th000
bucks on the Kansas City Chiefs that's
what I'm doing um I just think they're
going to win this game
it's you know the 49ers I listen I would
love to see the 49ers win this is just
my money talking and what the do I
know all right so I'm not going like
dude I know this I'm just telling
you what I'm doing take a th000 bucks
I'm putting it on the Kansas City
Chiefs um I think at this point Travis
Kelce is just he's just not coverable
you just just cannot cover the
guy cuz everybody
knows you're going to him and not only
not only is he open he's wide
open and every game it's like
well you know the linebacker thinks he
has help over the top and he passes him
off and then Kelsey's just running
alone you know with his hand in
the
air like that guy in the Colts right at
the half where what's his face didn't
see him Earl moral didn't see
him down the sidelines
um
anyway
um I think it's going to be a great game
but I'm actually really excited to go to
this because I've never seen Patrick I'm
going to the game with verie I've never
seen uh Patrick Mahomes
live I'm not excited to sit there for
those ridiculously long commercial
breaks and I just have a feeling that
you know cuz it's the Super Bowl like
during
those those you know those commercial
breaks oh my God the air quote
entertainment that they're going to
have some cancer survivor with the
ukulele that was in the Coast Guard you
know he's a first responder he's got a
ukulele and he survived cancer every
take your hats off and stand up it's
just like I don't know what they've done
to sports sports used to be an escape
now it is a reminder of how cruel God is
and how cruel man is to one another it's
just you know it's just like
enough
already and I swear to God if I'm at the
Super Bowl and there was some jerk off
on the
microphone going you know that's our
first
down second and Sh ball on the 42 I love
how they got to be like we're watching
football We're
Men that would be like one of you guys
out there that's good at hacking can you
guys just hack into that and
just be like first and 10 on the 36 look
at the Buns on that guy and just do it
until the FBI shows up at your
house
um no I should embrace it embrace it I
should embrace it I'm really looking
forward to I wonder who's going to be
DJing the
the Super
Bowl
um anyway they just take all the drama
out of it with those 10-minute
commercial breaks it's so it's
the most important game of the year I
still maintain this the last two
football games of the year are the AFC
and the NFC championship game and then
the Super Bowl is a is a football game
wrapped in a
show
um
my goal
is I don't know who the is singing
to start
it uh my goal is to miss
that and wrers they're going shoot that
poison arrow through my heart shoot that
poison arrow thank you good night you
know and then are you ready for
the right I can't hear you all that dumb
I got me earplugs in and then I
walk down to my seat
I got a dime on the game you know I got
a little Coke
spoon so I can be as amped up as the
guy screaming in my ear is going
to be um the big thing that I really am
excited is about this weekend is uh on
on Saturday night at 8:00
pm Paul verie and myself are going to be
at Brad Garrett's Comedy Club doing
uh alive anything better and uh I can't
wait for that I feel like it's it's just
going to be our people it's going to be
football fans
gamblers and uh you know just sports
fans and all that it's going to be
everything is that the Super Bowl isn't
where it's just going to be a bunch of
other people that don't even
like you know watch football that got
some sort of corporate hooked up or
something all right let's do the um
let's do the reads here for the week uh
what do we got here where are my reads
what did I do with them oh there they
are oh look who it is
everybody it is old
zip
[Music]
[Applause]
RR our friends at zip recruiter
conducted a recent survey this is fresh
information and found that the top
hiring challenge employers fa for 2020
for is a lack of qualified
candidates there's too many dumb Dums
out there but if you're an employer and
need to hire here's good news
zip it has smart tools and features that
help you find more qualified candidates
fast and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com burb RR here is
how
zip tools zip recruiters trols TR
tools and features help you find the
best people for your roles as soon as
you post your job on zip powerful
matching technology shows you candidates
whose skills and experience match it you
can use
zip invite to apply feature invite to
apply feature to send top candidates a
personalized invite encourage them to
respond to your job post when you use zi
Rec crew
ratings
tool to rate your candidates they send
you more matches from new profiles that
are created on site in other words they
look at what you responded to and they
start bringing you more like if you were
on a dating app all right this guy's in
the
blonds all right this guy likes a great
ass you know they're doing that but
with employees let zip recruit to help
you conquer the biggest hiring challenge
finding qualified cand candidates cy4 to
five employees who post on
zip get a quality candidate that's me
almost going off the off the zip
recruiter right my last read uh within
the first day find a quality candidate
within the first day just go to this
exclusive web address right now to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
bur again that's ziprecruiter.com SLB
spellout bur B RR zip
recruiter yeah smartest way to hire all
right what else we got here oh it's
stamps.com
dude you know after the hype of the new
year we all start to settle into our
routines but for businesses who do a lot
of mailing and shipping you got to keep
moving stamps.com streamlines all your
mailing and shipping to turbocharge your
operational efficiencies and the
stamps.com C com app is like a post
office in your pocket so you can stay on
top of things even if you're always on
the go postage rates just increased
again luckily stamps.com has been the
has the best discounts in the industry
with rates you can't find anywhere else
like up to 89% off USPS and UPS rates
plus stamps.com automatically tells you
your cheapest and fastest shipping
options so you don't have to navigate
all the different carriers for 25 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses whether
they're mailing out checks invoices
legal documents books or anything else
get access access to the
USPS the did I just do where the
hell did it
go get access to the USPS and UPS
mailing services you need to run your
business right from your computer
anytime day or night no lines no traffic
no waiting keep your mailing and
shipping moving at the speed of your
business with stamps.com sign up with
the promo code bur B for a special offer
that includes a 4-we trial plus free
postage and free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click the mic phone at
the top of the homepage and enter the
code bur b r r all right let's get into
the reads man the reads people have
questions
man they got a lot of questions I went
on a good flight the other day
though flew out to bracket bracket um I
saw this thing on Instagram there's this
cool bowling alley out there I want to
fly out there with one of my buddies and
go check it out once I'm done with this
fast I will tell you this though right
after this I'm going to the gym and I'm
doing my cardio you know doing a little
bit of cardio here and uh old Billy
little
middle still got a little bit of dough
here I got enough to make like a
personal size pizza that's the kind of
fat I have on my stomach I still I got
to get that down to a canoli all right
and then get it down to like a garlic
knot and then just be done with it all
right MMP for 25 Bill great
emails by the way there's a few tickets
left for the Patrice O'Neal Comedy
benefit the 11th annual incredible
lineup with an absolute monster for a
special guest um who will not be
advertised and uh let's just say you're
going to be very excited and uh it's
March I believe 26 that's a Tuesday at
the New York City
Center um put together every year by the
amazing Moren Taran she is the engine
behind the whole thing she's the captain
of the ship so thank you to Morin
Taran um the best in the business and
incredible taste in Comedians and every
year she helps me put together the
roster and by helps me I mean she
basically does it um so thank you to her
all right escape from New york/ St Louis
um I actually watched that movie the
other day and I really enjoyed it hadn't
seen it in a while
fantastic excuse me hi Bill big fan and
thanks for all the laughs you're welcome
I heard on the podcast that you just
watched Escape From New York I really
like that movie too it's a classic 80s
Sci-Fi Action flick that I think still
holds up if you don't take it too
seriously which I honestly think is the
way Carpenter and Russell intended it
yeah it's a lot of uh it's a lot of fun
it's it's 100% still held up hey it's on
the Criterion channel it's it's
obviously a quality movie right uh the
music is great and love all the little
details too like Isaac Hayes Cadillac
with the chandeliers attached to the
front is amazing I like that too uh I
don't know if you know this or not but
it was actually shot in St
Louis you know the brains Hideout that's
actually the Fox Theater get the
out of here I play that
place the place you've played and are
about to play again in a couple of
months the part of town that part of
town had a big fire in
1976 and the city just never cleaned it
up so it worked perfect for
postapocalyptic dystopian New York I
finally learned what dystopian means
means it takes place in the future and
Society has unraveled it's it's worse
than it is now um something like that I
probably said it wrong Carpenter
convinced the city to shut off
electricity to that part of the town for
shooting and the rest is history
I didn't know
that thank you for that thanks for
everything and go make sweet passionate
love to yourself also if you're
interested here is a like a link I think
you meant to an article and a short
documentary of course I don't have the
link I'll get it from Andrew
um by the way by the way by the way I
watched um a couple of more Oscar
nominated Best Picture movies I watched
um anatomy of a
fail
which the performances in the writing in
that
movie
are so next level everybody in that
movie is just absolutely amazing and I
just love what you're left with in the
end of it rather than leading you by the
nose and you're like you know you know
this is right and this is wrong here's
your happy Hollywood ending blah blah
blah it's just a
one of the realest endings to a
movie I can I can
remember and all of the performances
right down to the the the the kid who's
like 11 years old he's amazing the guy
who plays the prosecuting attorney is
incredible the defendant the whole
fraking thing is just uh fantastic
um big thumbs up to that one and then
also saw killers of the flower
Moon which I was intimidated by because
it was three and a half
hours like it flies
by and then you know once Jesse pl's
character shows up and you want to see
how it's all sorted out like I kept
going like all right I'm going to watch
this in two days I'll watch an hour and
45 and an hour and 45 and I just
couldn't shut the thing off the
only reason why I ended up having to
shut it off cuz I had to go out do a set
last night I got 40 minutes left
um it's it's unbelievable it might
be it's up there with my favorite Martin
scorsi
movies
um just first of all every shot that I'm
looking at I'm just thinking like how
long did he have to wait for that light
how did he get those horses to be there
one just like opening shot like on this
like cabin out on this the prairie in
Oklahoma and
it's just gorgeous the
the the topography meeting the sky
perfect clouds in the sky and then these
horses right down in the lower leftand
corner I'm just go look look look at
that will you look at
that you know what that reminds me I saw
I saw the hateful eight in 70
mm and uh that opening scene when the
the GU they driving the stage
coach in 70 M millimeter with a full
team of horses is one of my favorite
shots of of all time oh Billy Hollywood
look at he directs one movie and
all of a sudden he's uh James Lipton um
so anyway highly recommend all those
I'll tell you the best pictures this
year you know so i' I've gotten through
almost half of them and there's not one
stinkeroo in there they did a really
good job with the nominees there's
usually one where you're just like what
that got nominated for best picture all
right what's it about there's got to be
somebody has to have AIDS or
something you know there's always like
the themes that they always gravitate is
it cruelty to animals what's going on
here there's got to be a reason they
picked this because I don't understand
you know but not this year everything's
fantastic so far all right Farmers
Revolt hey Billy Roy greatting from
London um have you I love doing a bad
London accent and then them telling me
that I do a bad like they do a good
English accent um have you been
following the farmers revolt
I
haven't to catch you up to catch you up
in case you haven't psycho climate
activists are trying to get farmers in
Ireland to Cull which basically means to
thin the herd by killing a
percentage oh because of the the the
cows
farting uh it's usually done if there's
a drought or food shortage it's much
more Humane than letting it start plus
who wants to haul off slimy dead cows
anyways all these multinational
corporations and politicians have
schemed to control the food supply so
much that they're using the law to tell
Farmers to kill their healthy cattle
it's really disgusting they claim it
reduces carbon Bill killing these cows
hurting Farmers income and reducing food
supply won't even put a cair of a dent
in the Cal total carbon in the
atmosphere no it
won't dude we're heading to some dark
days here there's one volcano that
erupted last year that emitted more
carbon than all of humans in the last
10,000 years it's a scam so they can
keep making plastic and dumping
chemicals while they're telling us what
the to
do yeah that's 100% it and I'm going to
tell you all you idiots who go
on social media and say
libtards and uh conservatives
their sisters and blah blah blah and all
of this um you're playing into
their hands what we need to do is we
need to come together we have to be on
the same page cuz make no mistake it's
US versus them and that's why we're
fighting so much with each other because
that's exactly what the they want
they literally have Bots that go on
social media to start arguments
uh these people are pure evil
and that's one of the things that I
loved about um killers of the flower
moon is not only do they
show
uh the greed of some people when it
comes to
money uh it also kind of shows how it
goes down where it's like with all of
those things you have the devil and the
dummies the devil and the devil's
dummies so the Devil comes up with this
scheme and then he gets the dummies to
carry out and frames it in their
head so they can make sense of what it
is that they're doing and uh it's Robert
Dao's my favorite performance of
his since I don't know what I can't
maybe
heat um not saying I haven't enjoyed his
performances but like this he's just so
unbelievable in this movie and learo
DiCaprio of course is always great I'm
I'm going to give a shout out to
everybody when I when I finish this
movie but um
yeah we need to
uh we need to all get on the same page
and stop yelling at each
other about in this country about
Joe Biden and Donald Trump it
doesn't matter those two
idiots don't matter they they're the
matred welcome to the United States can
you know what do you need a four toop
like that's they don't own the
restaurant it's what I'm saying they
work for people
um so I don't know I think that the
common man needs to be nice and
respectful to one another we need to
listen to one another and we need to
stop yelling at each other and just
looking at this small group of people at
the top that are absolutely out of their
minds the direction that they're
driving the bus in all right that's my
that's my uh my little uh you
know my little Soliloquy for the week
all right what do we got here this says
bill you called it oh did I you called
it all steroid
Olympics oh yeah I did a bit about that
a long time ago hey Billy the buff look
like some billionaires have been
listening to your podcast and now
they're funding an all juice Olympics
they call it the enhanced
games enhanced in certain areas but
their balls are all shriveled up and the
press release says the enhanced games
the modern reinvention of the Olympic
Games that does not have drug
testing oh my God I want to see a
bearded lady clean jerk like a thousand
pounds uh billionaires like
PayPal founder Peter theal see the
vision of a new model of sports that
openly celebrates scientific innovation
and honestly represents the use of
performance enhancements in sports
today well that's interesting if you
don't demonize steroids and you
let I mean it's weird like steroids are
demonized in sports but if you're a
singer
you know and you got to sing tip throw
Through the Tulips at night and your
voice is you know under the weather
they'll give you a steroid right
so
um I don't know would you watch an all
steroid football league are these
billionaires just testing new drugs for
their super soldier private militias are
we in an 80 sci-fi movie I would say yes
to all of
that um I would watch an all steroid
football league I think I kind of do
already uh are these billionaires just
testing new drugs for their super
soldiers pra oh 100%
100% um CVS is doing that the grocery
stores are doing that like we're all
Lab Rats that was the funny
thing about you know people drawing the
line like I'm not going to get the
vaccine which really was just a
booster
um people drew the Line in the Sand
there but you know I just watched the
thing the other day that said like
Quaker Oats was I've eaten my whole life
like the level of poison that's in that
and I'm like okay now now do I believe
this what do I like if half the
that they're saying is true like they're
yeah the the whole this whole thing is
an
experiment um but I maintain they can't
stop you from having a good time and
they can't stop you from deciding to be
a sweetheart and just be nice to people
just be empathetic that guy's trying to
come in your lane just let him do it
give him the thumbs
up that's it I'm trying to do that next
time why why' you learn how to
drive you just be like yeah you're right
sorry I didn't see you it's a bonehead
move you're 100% right sorry about that
you just see they don't know what to do
with it
um I don't know or maybe I'm just
oversimplifying it I mean that's
my only solution like I can't watch I
mean I did we just go to war with Iran
is this Joe Biden's way of trying to
stay in office you know what I mean
which is another funny thing that I just
love how liberals think Liberals are
liberal
I mean Bill Clinton didn't he bomb a
country to get the whole that whole
away from him you know I
mean these these people did not human
they're not human it's like you
decide to do this and you drop bombs
they don't just land on the people you
you're you're killing people's families
like they're
unbelievable he's a liberal he wants to
give everything away now he's over here
bombing a country that guy is
about as liberal as uh I don't
know
what um Eastern Europe in the '
80s uh all right a hard one dear bill
this is going to be a sad letter so if
you don't feel like dealing with this
today I understand all right yeah
this letter I'm not reading it no
truthfully I think I'm writing you for
the same reason Catholics go to
confession don't worry I know you can
absolve me of my sins five years ago I
switched jobs when I when and when I did
I rolled my company 401K into what's
known as a self-directed 401 K my family
and I also moved that year and I took
the proceeds from the house sale and
dumped those into an individual account
with the same broker oh God it wasn't
much by some people's standards but dude
if it's all you have it's a lot it
wasn't much by some people's standards
but between the two accounts it amounted
to our life
savings I did what any sane person would
do and bought a bunch of safe stuff and
tried not to look at it very often
then came the pandemic I actually sold
everything at the perfect time
yes
okay oh please tell me you didn't get
into
Bitcoin I think I was the second or
third it was the second or third week in
February before everything really went
to hell but I took a long long time
getting back in and when I did I didn't
play it safe
anymore oh boy this has too many
twists and turns here for a year I did
very well and doubled our life savings
and during that whole time it never
occurred to me the real risk I was taken
Q though oh Jesus fast forward to
yesterday and it's been two solid years
of bad decision after bad decision after
bad decision first I was long when
everything was
going to down
hard what first I was long when
everything was going I think going down
hard in 2022 then I was short when
everything was just kept going up up up
in 2023 an absolute epic meltdown
brought by tens on by tens if not
hundreds of individual bad decisions so
here I am it's early February and
there's basically nothing left I know
you're probably thinking I'm some
degenerate gambling addict but I swear
it's not true true I don't bet on Sports
only been to casino twice in my life and
probably lost $150 combine I drive a
20-year-old SUV and live in a regular
house don't drink don't smoke I just got
over overwhelmed slowly at first then
all at once my question is simple how do
I forgive
myself how does a man forgive himself
when his selfish and foolish actions
cost the people he loves thanks for any
advice you can give and thanks for all
the laughs over the years God bless and
go didd
yourself
uh easy you take responsibility for your
actions you apologize to everybody and
you promis that you're going to do
everything in your efforts to make it
right and then you go out and you do
that and um the worst thing you can do
right now is act like the game's over
your life is over this is a moment in it
and you know what you've built yourself
a
great
preamble to the story of your
success of losing it all and coming back
do you know how many successful people I
know that have lost it all and then came
back
um six Success is Not trying something
going out being successful and being and
then that's it it's not a
linear thing um
Journey success is just stepping out
into the abyss and free falling into
something hitting the water and then
trying to swim and there's moments where
it's white water and then it
becomes calm and then there's a
waterfall
and what it
is is not allowing yourself to get too
down or too or too high and keeping
between your ears positive which is what
you need right now cuz right now you're
beating yourself up it's time that the
pity party is over just tell your wife
that just be like listen I want you to
know that the pity you know I still feel
unbelievable shame for what I did but
the pity party is over and I'm going to
make you proud of me again and and then
you just go out and you just
whatever the direction is that you want
to be going in I don't know what you do
for a living
um and you build it back up again and
I'm going to tell you something you will
get you
know if you do that if you don't just
look at this like this is the end of
your journey it's the beginning of your
big
comeback okay
um I feel that you know your family's
always going to love you they're to be
now they're going to be like looking at
you like you're going to teach them you
can actually give them A Life Lesson
here so the life lesson here is you know
you don't stick all your eggs in one
basket and I hate to tell you this but
Wall Street you might as well go into a
Cino Casino it happens quicker but Wall
Street is 100% rigged I mean the
House and Senate voted that they can't
get tried for insider trading they make
a couple hundred grand a year they're
all their portfolios generally speaking
are worth upward ward of $20
million okay they're getting all sign
kinds of insider trading there's a bunch
of different ways to make money still in
this country
um and I think the fact that you're
conservative at heart is a good
thing it seems like you just got a
little crazy so just learn from this
lesson and uh tell yourself you're going
to figure it out and go figure
it out
um my standup career I mean I
I I've had so many ups and
downs in this thing
where you know sometimes things that
were supposed to be good this happens it
actually leads to like a down period or
whatever and I like I had
periods starting off nobody knowing who
I was and then all of a sudden people
knowing who I am you know getting big
gigs having a manager and big
agency then all of a sudden cools
off my agency I've been dropped by like
I don't know how many
agencies have dropped me um I've been
fired by
managers I've gone all the way from
being out here in LA and having a
one-bedroom apartment and driving a car
to losing all of that going back to my
walkthrough bedroom apartment living
with Bobby Kelly now and we shared the
walkth through bedroom part like he
slept in the living room on a pullout
couch you know becoming
unincorporated and just went through a 6
sevene period of just like trying to put
it all back together again just not
being able to get arrested before I
started to get it going
again and
um and even then like I I still have
like like setbacks you know I I got a
really good role in this
movie and I was thinking like oh man
this is going to be a great thing I'll
get to do the talk show circuit you know
maybe I'll get some good press I can
start get some better acting roles and
then the pandemic comes and the movie
comes comes out during the pandemic does
really well but you know didn't get to
do the hype I do old dads I'm all
excited about it I'm really blah blah
blah blah blah and it comes out
during the strike and it was this
massive
hit that no one really talked about cuz
it did that and it's just you know those
are like little gut punches I mean the
amount of time that me and Ben tishel
put in that movie it was like a
it was like four years of our
lives and it just kind of you
know came out and very quietly crushed I
mean it did amazing and it's definitely
opened some doors but you know I didn't
get to do like what everyone was telling
me Oh my god when this thing comes out
we're going to get you on this show
you're going to be on the cover of this
magazine you're that nothing none of
that happened so even when you're like
being successful like like this
still happens you know what you
say you just go what am I
special
is no bad supposed to happen to me
every person in the business
that I am
in can sit down and talk way longer
about getting kicked in the nuts than
they can about going over the moon
because
um that's kind of what life is you know
it's like this
you know you win and then the
next day there's another game and you
might lose at that games that's
where you're at man you you know you had
a bad season you lost some games you're
on a losing streak you just got to
turn it around and success is
really so much of it is how you handle
when you get your dick knocked in the
dirt and if you could just go
all right Nice Shot dust yourself up you
know Hulk Hogan that they go to
drop your hand that last time and you
stop it you put it up in the air
and you start nodding your head
you get up to one knee that's just what
you got to do it just really is and I'm
telling you man don't believe all of
this
that people say about Hollywood
where they uh you know because these
idiot actors got to Ram their
politics down everybody's throat so now
everybody's like saying Hollywood
this whole idea that everybody is out
here just sitting around a pool
not doing anything like
um when I get into business to do a
project I am always astounded at how
hard people work they are like they're
psychotic the level that they work
they're
like
Workaholics I mean I'm talking 13 14
hours a day and they don't get paid
overtime it's just it's just what it is
day in and day out Monday through Friday
and then on the weekends your phone is
blowing up with a zillion
goddamn questions when you know you're
trying to shoot a TV series or a movie
it's like they're out there everybody is
busting their ass but what does the
paparazzi show they show people
vacationing and in wherever the
they go some
Island um and even then that's worked
because they call the paparazzi they're
not the feds they don't know
where you're at they call the
paparazzi you know they don't eat for
a bunch of days and then they
put on a bathing suit and then they got
to have that oh oh you caught me
look it's all that's even their
vacation is work so anyway I'm
sorry this happened to you but
you're going to turn it around
okay and and that what's great about
life is when you get in the mindset that
um your success and your failure is
nothing more than your decision so
whatever you decide to do you can make
the decision that this event in
the stock market is
what destroyed you and then you can go
down to some stupid bar and tell your
Sad Sack story to some other sad
sack who's also decided that they're a
loser in Life or you can just decide
that hey man I took a nice shot
got knocked on my ass and I'm
getting up and I'm going to come back
even stronger this time all right that's
what I hope for you okay there you go
there's your halftime speech all
right and that is the podcast
everybody that is the podcast
um yeah I don't know what else to say go
yourselves have a great couple of
days I'll check in on you on Thursday
the All-Star NHL weekend is over and uh
I'm looking forward to uh watching a
little bit of hockey I'm enjoying
watching the Celtics but I I had to be
honest about that loss that was
not uh that's not what a championship
team does so uh I don't know that's my
two cents all right that's it
I'll talk to you guys in a few
days